there's no such thing as too long only
too boring same person who gets bored 3
seconds into a 10-second video May bch a
television series for 8 hours straight
the competition for attention has just
raised the bar is higher so it's not
that people have shorter attention
stands they have higher standards
because there's so many other places
they can look to get a reward for their
attention that they're just not
satisfied with mediocrity people used to
sit around the radio as a family and
listen to it why doesn't that happen
anymore our environment has changed and
since the environment is changed so too
as our Behavior so we just have to make
sure that we're better than everybody
else that is competing for their
eyeballs